zach gallon set to go and here he is
your diamondback starting pitcher
tonight
it's been some up and down for gallon
this year winless in his last four
starts beaten by these dodgers in la
last monday
called strike three with a fastball
three pitches three strikes to mookie
betts good start
gets past the catcher carson kelly down
to second base go seeger so one out one
entree turner coming up
there's the changeup and he gets the
strikeout of turner with that changeup
two outs of the first
got him
another fastball gallon gets three
strikeouts in the first 21st start for
clayton kershaw is ten and seven
and three two seven eras looked good in
his first two starts off the injured
list
tell martay jumps on the first pitch
drives it to left field has gone
that's the way to start one nothing
diamondbacks well you talk about an
ambush looking for that first pitch
heater he got it didn't miss it dodgers
very patient in there at bats in the top
of the first cattell martay
less so in the home half
he almost pops it up
muncie drifting under it
that's the first out of the arizona
first best chance of getting to him as
well
russia hits the ball well to right field
going back is bets
and right there at the edge of the
warning track will
on two down
owen two walker the hitter carson kelly
on deck the pitch to walker swung on and
missed strike three on the slider
swinging a miss on the fastball that's
four strikeouts for gallon who's punched
out for the first five
swing and a miss gallon five outs and
five strikeouts to start the night two
up two down as he gets turner swinging
swinging into this he got him
gallon strikes out the side he's punched
out six of the first seven carson kelly
leads off the second against clayton
kershaw
kelly down the line and left as he got
it it is gone back to back first and
second hitting home runs by catel martin
now carson kelly and it's two nothing
diamondbacks well the lead off pitters
are really doing the job here getting
for the diamondbacks
as kelly blistered that ball right into
the diamondbacks bullpen
send this one home and the 1-0 is
bounced to the right side muncie will
take care of it for the first out of the
arizona second
two one on the ground right side once
he's got it spins throws to cedar the
return throw gets away with kershaw
covering but
mccarthy unable to move up anywhere
two-two
strike three looking got him with a
slider
[Applause]
there's one put in the
field of play and that's taken by walker
at first base
swinging a fly ball to left and it's
caught out there by ramos
center field mccarthy
his there
gallon walk two left them both out there
and it's still two nothing serpientes
swinging a miss by muncie down on
strikes smith the strikeout victim to
lead off the second
hard to shore to lamarro vargas
round ball out on a cutter two outs he's
on the move
taylor popped it up light sky up there
for mccarthy
roof is open
and now the 1-2 pitch
curve ball is hit in the air right field
mookie betts right in his tracks
first down of the diamondback
next saturday is the last saturday of
the regular season rojas a little
baltimore chop
in front of the mound
coming out from behind the plate
is will smith to make the play to first
there was no chance of getting walker at
second
august reached on an error by corey
seeger's first time up seeker had to
charge one kind of bobbled it a little
bit
[Applause]
justin turner at third high throw
walker's coming home
oh that was an easy play they should
have been out of the inning turner threw
it away and it's three-nothing
diamondbacks you saw that coming he
fielded the high hop over his head and
never really came down to set his feet
[Music]
got him
strike three and that is career
strikeout number
2669
moving kershaw into 26th place all time
a major league strikeout list
sky's this one deep to center mccarthy
has room
nice job right there just a long out
trying another breaking ball
martay at second
next one to him with two outs there he
swung a one grounded down to third
fielded by rojas and across the diamond
in time one two three with the dodgers
in the fifth
[Applause]
punches that one into center marte three
for three
good start to the fifth two on no outs
henry ramos
ground ball down to third turner one
safe at second safe at first was hoping
to get at least two maybe even three
they only got one and now it's a chance
for dalton varshall
the way he's hit the ball lately and he
knocks it into left center here comes
martay this will make it four-nothing
diamondbacks varsho the rbi turner is
struck out wide to center
and a fly ball to left field and deep if
it's fair it's gone and it is fair and
long gone trade turner with a home run
is 23rd of the year the dodgers are on
the board the diamondback lead has been
trimmed to 4-1 well a breakthrough and
hopefully that gets the dodgers out of
their doldrums
cole calhoun has looked terrific since
returning from the injured list last
weekend after the hamstring injury
calhoun right center that drops in here
comes mccarthy here's the throw it's cut
off 5-1 diamondbacks carl calhoun
for he has been terrific since he came
off the hamstring injury all right
here's peralta announces a pitch hitter
two walks in the ending two on two out
and that one drops in here comes two
more
it's seven to one
[Applause]
and turner hits the ball well to left
field this ball is gone his second home
run of the game
trey turner
24th home run of the season
lifts it out to center jake mccarthy is
there diamondbacks win the ball game
you